et
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale à ryder cup l'ambiance
monte ici au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
reviendrons sur ce premier jour de
compétition dans cette émission et ils
nous parleront également de tout ce qui
s'est passé à cette semaine avec les
meilleures images
[Musique]
tous
on est au départ du trou numéro un de la
première journée de compétition et
l'ambiance est tout simplement
indescriptible il y a environ entre
trente et quarante mille personnes sur
votre numéro un
[Applaudissements]
et les supporters se sont levés très tôt
pour assister à ce premier jour de
compétition je suis justement avec
pierre qui nous vient tout droit de
paris pierre vous êtes levés à quelle
heure ce matin 14 matin pour arriver ici
vers 6h envers prépare 13h30 et premier
rang super bonne ambiance
s'ils partent mosphere heureuse est là
pas trop fatigué fatigué l'adrénaline
tout le monde tout autour on chante on
danse depuis depuis 6 heures c'est à
séron chouette c'est mythique
ce premier tron s'est métissé 3 celles
annoncées le crafting c'est toutes les
stars qu'on voit à la télé états unis et
en europe
c'est extraordinaire vous laisse
profiter on regarde ce classique
justement les supporters sont en délire
c'est la première fois justement on
voulait à tout prix venir dire sur
l'événement pour vivre l'ambiance ont
séduit d'autres numéros justement et ça
c'est assez impressionnant
c'est sympa il ya une bonne atmosphère
c'est compliqué pour les golfeurs c'est
très bruyant c'est incroyable et bien
sûr l'ambiance devenu indescriptible
quant à tiger woods est arrivé à sur le
parcours on le voit juste d'armes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier soir c'était sympa simplement de
passer la soirée avec mes coéquipiers
avec tout le staff
et puis aujourd'hui bon c'était bien de
se détendre de se dégourdir les jambes
prendre un bon bol d'air les jouer au
golf
pour moi c'est incroyable de voir e
tiger woods beaucoup et je suis hyper
content sinon un peu une résurrection
d'un joueur qui était tombé très très
très bas et qui a été remontée qui a
monté avec beaucoup de volonté du
plaisir
ben parce que je suis impressionné
shi
impressionné parce qu'ils jouent bien la
ryder cup 2018 c'est aussi l'occasion de
voir de nombreuses célébrités à mardi
dernier il ya d'ailleurs eu un match des
célébrités qui a été organisée avec
l'acteur samuel l jackson et dany boon
c'est important d'être là aujourd'hui
demain et toute la semaine jusqu'à
dimanche pour soutenir l'équipe
européenne soutenir le golf national le
golf français
nous avons besoin de nous entraîner mais
j'espère gagner mon niveau de golf
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas encore
heureux heureux nerveux mais revu en
baisse et ouais jouer ici c'est quand
même c'est pas rien c'est pas banal
voilà quelques jours de la rider sur le
parcours voilà c'est un luxe fils au
caire je me sens bien je me sens plutôt
calme aujourd'hui je suis bien pour le
moment mais sur le premier trou je pense
que je ne serai pas serein et parmi les
personnalités y avait à bien sûr michael
jordan qui était présent au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
le coach michael jordan fait partie des
250 mille personnes présentes ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant cette
ryder cup une opportunité pour le
secteur hôtelier la table a va être sur
mon plein avec la différentes
nationalités des américains des
espagnols des italiens et des français
une quinzaine de passionnés de golf sont
attendus dans cette maison d'hôtes basée
à magny les hameaux pendant la semaine
de la ryder cup
l'établissement est complet nous allons
mettre les bouchées double triple
quadruple pour qu' il soit ils repartent
avec un souvenir inoubliable de cette
manifestation service de transfert
jusqu'au parking situé à
toussus-le-noble location de vélos la
responsable de cette maison d'hôtes a
tout préparé
et cela depuis plusieurs années les
personnes me contacter depuis plus de
sept ans et j'ai pris des des noms des
mails et des restes pré réservation mais
je n'ai rien réservé à une bonne assise
a ouvert les réservations le 30
septembre 2017 lui jours après c'est est
complet les tarifs ont été multipliées
par deux c'est le casseur de toutes les
réservations chaque personne j'ai fait
une une pochette par personne qui a
réservé le nombre de chambres les
nombres de nuit qui le souhaitent pour
les accueillir au mieux et ben je vois
exactement qui arrive quand qui
souhaitent un transfert qu'il souhaite
un vélo les hôtels vont également faire
le plein pendant la ryder cup sur saint
quentin en yvelines et dans les
agglomérations environnantes
cet événement est quand même très
positif à notre sens ce territoire déjà
pour la visibilité du territoire au
niveau touristique et puis au niveau
hébergements hôtels s'éteint c'est un
plus
bien sûr les hôtels sont sont quand même
très très remplis près de 70000
spectateurs sont attendus chaque jour au
golf national durant la semaine de la
ryder cup
nous allons faire à présent les magasins
direction la boutique officielle de
cette ryder cup 2018
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans un véritable temple
de la consommation à tous les clients
venus du monde entier peuvent acheter à
des tasses des ti peuvent h également
des clubs de golf ou des polos et
justement ils viennent du monde entier
et nous sommes avec brad qui nous vient
de houston dans le texas brad what have
you got a new bag
qu'est ce que vous avez dans votre sac
et a engagé un polo pour monfils
il a 11 ans et c'est un grand fan de la
ryder cup
j'ai la baisse de l'équipe américaine
parce qu'il fait un peu froid dehors il
ça permet de garder la chaleur et j'ai
une boîte de balles de golf
professionnel que je vais ramener à mon
ami à houston it's important for you to
have got something about the way back up
c'est important pour vous d'avoir ce tas
de choses pour la ryder cup 2018
absolument c'est vraiment génial d'être
ici à la ryder cup et je voulais avoir
des choses à ramener à la maison pour
pouvoir m'en souvenir good shoping voilà
brad va continuer son shopping et moi je
vais peut-être me laisser tenter
également
non
le monde
alors là on en a pour 50 euros
alors on est quand même très loin des
5100 12 euros dépensés par un américain
irs la ryder cup ne serait rien à 100 e
les volontaires ils sont 1 1500 sur
cette ryder cup 2018 et ils viennent du
monde entier
ils ne sont pas rémunérés mais ils sont
rémunérés à la passion nous avons
rencontré deux yvelinois il ya une
sélection qui est faite par le comité
d'organisation français américain en
fonction de dieu des rôles qui sont
attribués il ya 1500 bénévoles à peu
près et puis j'ai été choisi donc pour
pour gérer l le trou numéro 2 sur les
chiffres de l'après midi
et puis c'est aussi pour voir un petit
peu les les champions internationaux de
prêt et pouvoir vivre au coeur d'un
événement qui est le troisième
troisième événement médiatique au monde
donc une chance unique a pas laissé
passer tout comme pierre chevalier
jacques morny président du club de golf
de montigny le bretonneux a été
sélectionné pour participer à la ryder
cup 2018 comme bénévole il est sur le
practice d'entraînement mon rôle est si
basse et de ses dettes à leur service
anthony mais essentiellement de les
convoyant à leur fournir des balles
donc on a en a huit types de bal
différent donc c'est eux qui nous dise
quelle balle il tape que ben ali
souhaite taper et puis on leur donne le
sens ballon fait attention qu'il ne
manque pas de balle déclare sow
commencent à arriver dans leur demande
s'ils en veulent d'autres puissent ils
veulent d'autres vallées mais on le
ramène à sa soeur complémentaires et
ensuite on nettoie la place pour que le
suivant ait une place propre et qu'ils
soient bien à l'aise pour tabasser val
s'en prenait s'échaufferont
pour vivre pleinement cette ryder cup si
vous n'êtes pas présent au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
mettre en place une fan zone
cette dernière retransmettra l'événement
jusqu'à ce dimanche au centre commercial
espace saint quentin montigny le
bretonneux
elle était jeudi dernier en pleine
installation en parallèle de la
retransmission des matchs des animations
seront organisées il ya des activités
culturelles et sportives une sportive
plutôt golfique
il ya du petit goût du practice sur
l'eau la visite du golf national en
réalité virtuelle pour permettre
vraiment de découvrir le golf
autrement il ya l'écran géant avec la
retransmission complète de la
compétition sur les trois jours il ya du
coloriage des activités de lecture
golfique pour les enfants donc voilà ça
permet d'avoir plein d'animations autour
de la ryder cup
la fièvre de la ryder cup s'est
également emparée de versailles la ville
qui héberge les joueurs pendant la
compétition au trianon palace a décidé
d'organiser des animations devant le
château pour donner envie aux débutants
de se lancer dans le golfe
les activités sont ouvertes dès 6 ans
jusqu'à ce dimanche soir
l'un des moments forts de la semaine
également c'était la cérémonie
d'ouverture des concerts l'annoncent des
joueurs tout était réuni pour réaliser
un grand spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
important jamais publié de satisfaction
devant et
pouvait que par rapport au t1
cérémonie d'ouverture y avait encore
plus de passion
ça sera chez nous
l'image du jour ce sont ces supporters
américains on les appelle plus
communément les ultras américains et ils
viennent de très loin écoutez les nous
venons du minnesota nous aimons faire du
bruit
mais nous faisons aussi attention à
notre voie car nous chantons beaucoup
après ac premier match ce vendredi la
compétition continue ce week end samedi
il y aura encore des doubles le matin et
l'après midi dimanche place aux simples
à partir de 11 heures
en fin d'après-midi la coupe sera remise
au vainqueur
[Musique]
je vous propose maintenant de regarder
les plus belles images de cette semaine
de ryder cup
[Musique]
oh
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
à ryder cup à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures golfique
[Musique]
m